a cold January day of 2005 I took one of
my most important drive of my life I was
on this road in upstate New York trying
to find this old factory and they before
I received a flyer in the mail and said
fully equipped yogurt plant for sale
I drove it in the garbage can and 20
minutes later I picked it up and called
the number
Platt was 85 years old and it was
closing so I decided to go see it at
this time I wasn't sure where this road
or my life is going I own a small cheese
shop but really hated business but the
hills and the roads and the smells is
also familiar I grew up in Turkey the
similar environment near the Kurdish
mountains my family make cheese and
yogurt I grew up listening Shepherd
stories we didn't have much but we had
the moon and the stars simple food each
other and rationally I came to America I
didn't even know New York had forms I
made it to upstate and I never left now
I'm lost
I passed the road sign said dead-end and
as soon after there was the factory the
smell hit me first it was like a milk
container left out in the Sun the walls
were so thick panes were peeling there
were cracks everywhere the factory was
so old the owners thought it was
worthless I thought
they left a zero off couldn't I couldn't
believe the price as I entered in I
stopped focusing tea I stopped noticing
things all I could see were the people
there were fifty five of them it was
quiet their only job was to break the
plant apart and close it forever
I was met with a guy named rich
production manager he offered to take me
around show me around he didn't say much
but there on every corner he would point
out some stories rich worked there for
20 years his father made yogurt before
him and his grandfather made cream
cheese before that you could tell
they're rich felt guilty that this
factory was closing on his watch what
hit me the hardest at the time that this
wasn't just an old factory this was a
time machine this is where people built
lives they left for wars they brag about
homeruns and record cards but now it was
closing and the company wasn't just
giving up on yogurt it was giving up on
them as if they were not good enough and
I was shocked how these people were
behaving there were no anger there was
no tears just silence with grace they
were closing this Factory I was so angry
that the CEO of far away in a tower or
somewhere looking at the spreadsheets
and closing the factory spreadsheets are
lazy they don't tell you about people
they don't tell you about community
but unfortunately this is how too many
business decisions are made today I was
never the same person after what I saw
on my way back home I called Mario my
lawyer
I called Mario I said Mario I want to
buy beans by this place
Mario said handy weren't the largest
food company in the world is closing
this place and they're getting out of
yogurt business who the hell are you to
make it work I said you're right but the
next day I called him again and I said
Mario really I really want to buy this
place
he's a ham that you have no money you
haven't even paid me in six months which
was true but I got along another loan by
August 2005 I had the keys for this
Factory the first thing I did was to
hire four of the original 55 people I
had Maria office manager
I had Frank the wastewater guy I had
Mike the maintenance guy and rich was
show me the plant production guy and we
had our first board meeting Mike's
family what are we going to do now so
they look at me as if I have the magic
answer so I said Mike we're going to go
to Ace Hardware store and we're going to
get some paints and we're going to paint
the walls outside Mike wasn't impressed
he looked at me he said how many that's
fine we'll do that but tell me you have
more ideas than that
I said I do we'll paint the walls white
honest to god that was the only ideas I
had but we painted those walls that
summer I sometimes wonder what they
would have said to me if I told them see
these walls we are painting in two years
we're going to lunch a yogurt here that
Americans never seen and never tasted
before
will be delicious it would be natural
and we're gonna call it Chobani it means
shepherd in Turkish and if I said we
were going to hire all of the 55
employees back or most of them back and
then hundreds more after and 100 more
after and then thousand more after that
but if I told them you see that town
over there
every person we hire 10 more local jobs
will be created the town will come back
to life the trucks will be all over the
roads and the first money we make we're
going to build one of the best little
league baseball field for our children
and five years after that we're going to
be the number one Greek yogurt brand in
the country would they have believed me
of course not but that's exactly what
happens
in painting those walls we got to know
each other we believed in each other and
we figured it out together five years me
and all my colleagues we never left the
factory we worked day and night to the
holidays to fix that plant the best part
of Chobani for me is this the same exact
people who were giving up on where the
ones built it back 100 times better than
before and they all have a financial
stake in the company today and all these
times I kept wondering you see another
business man I don't come from that
tradition I just kept wondering what is
this all about the corporate American
says it's about profits mainstream
business says about money this year
playbook says about shareholders and
there's so much is sacrifice for it
it's factories communities jobs but not
by CEOs CEOs have their employees suffer
for them but yet the CEOs pay up goes up
and up and up and so many people's are
left behind I'm here to tell you no more
it's not right it's never been right
it's time to admit that the PlayBook
that guided businesses and CEOs for the
last 40 years is broken
it tells you everything about business
except how to be a noble leader we need
a new playbook
we need a new playbook that sees people
again that sees above and beyond profits
in the movies they have a name for
people who take a different path to do
things right they call them anti-heroes
I think we need the same idea in
business we need anti CEOs and we need
an to see your PlayBook so let me tell
you about what this anti see your
PlayBook is all about anti see your
PlayBook is about gratitude today's
business book says business exists to
maximize profit for the shareholders I
think that's the dumbest idea I've ever
heard in my life in reality business
should take care of their employees
first you know a few years ago when we
announced that we're going to have you
given shares to all our 2,000 employees
some people said it's you know PR some
said it's a gift I said it's not a gift
I washed it I've been part of it they
earned it with their talent and with
your hard work and I don't see any other
way the new way of business
it's your employees you take care of
first
not the profits the new anti senior
playbook is about community today the
businesses that have it all ask for
communities what kind of tax braces
incentives you can give me the reality
is businesses should go to the
struggling communities and ask how can I
help you
you know when we wanted to build our
second yogurt plant Idaho was in
nobody's radar screen it was to rural
too far away didn't have much incentives
so I went there I met with the local
people I met with the farmers we shook
hands we broke bread I said I want to
build it right here I don't need to see
financial studies in the result this
community is thriving there's new
schools are opening every year flats new
food companies are coming up every year
and they told me you're not going to
find any trained workers here I said
it's okay we'll teach them we partnered
with the local community college and
what we were building the plant we
trained hundreds of hundreds of people
for advanced manufacturing and today our
factory is one of the largest yogurt
plant in the world the movie of business
communities go search for communities
that you can be part of ask for
permission and be be with them open the
walls and succeed together the antici
your PlayBook is about responsibility
today's play book says the businesses
should stay out of politics
the reality is businesses as citizens
mastica site when we were growing in New
York and looking for more people to hire
I remembered in Utica and our way they
were refugees from Southeast Asia and
Africa we are looking for what place to
work they all speak English someone told
me I said I don't really either
let's get translators
they don't have transportations I said
let's get buses it's not a rocket
science today one of the Americas rural
areas
30% of Chobani workforce are immigrants
and refugees and it changed us for
better do new way of business its
business not government is in the best
position to make a change in today's
world in gun violence in in climate
change in in the income inequality in
refugees in race it's business must take
aside and lastly auntie CEO playbook is
about accountability today's play book
says the CEO reports to the boards
couple boards in my opinion see your
reports to consumer in the first few
years of Shabani the 1-800 number was in
the cup was my personal number when
somebody called him wrote I responded
personally sometimes I made it changes
based on what I heard because consumer
is in power that's the reason the
business exists it's you every single
one of you is in the power to make it
changes today if you don't like the
brand and the companies what they are
doing with their business we can throw
them into the garbage can and if you see
the ones that doing it right we can
reward them in the end this is all in
our responsibility the new way of
business
it's consumer we report to not to the
corporate boards you see if you are
right with your people if you're right
with your community if you're right with
your product you will be more profitable
you will be more innovative you'll have
more passionate people working for you
and the community that supports you and
that's what the
Phantasy your PlayBook is all about the
treasure that I found in that factory
dignity of work strike of character
human spirit what we need to unleash all
across the world brothers and sisters
there are people and places all around
the world left out and left behind but
their spirit is still strong they just
want another chance they want someone to
give them a chance again not to just
build it back but build it better than
before and this is the difference
between return on investment and return
on kindness this is the difference
between profit and true wealth and if he
can't happen in upstate New York in a
small town upstate New York in Idaho it
can happen in every city and town and
village across the world this is not the
time to build walls this is a time to
start painting the walls I leave the
colors all after you thank you so much